えっっ
今日は
水2月25日チャンネル登録しちゃっ数が
残り30万円で1000万円でっていうの
が出した日ですさっきまでテンションが
上がりすぎてみた叫んでたんすけど以下1
体1体を見てくださいね
[音楽]
山が自己
いけませんか
わー
ああ
クレイジーカーフやったやったそうなん
ですよています考えておりますちょっと
やらせだと思ったけどできますね何もない
んでしょいきますよいきますよいきますよ
何も入れてない状況でた彼のがやっぱ
正しい
測定子だと思うのです
入れすぎるあっくっっパック2
ちゃんずクロスさんっはいこんにちは皆
さんはじめ社長です残り30万人で手マン
にがんばるぞって者減だ瞬間
さん繕う声の熱が出てしまいます笑ぐらい
寒気がすごいですもう普通に体の限界すぎ
て色々準備してもらったんですけどなんか
僕年に3度ぐらい兆候月の神作画で倒れる
癖がついてもちろんちょっと来ローダーの
可能性もゼロではないということで一旦
しっかりを削ぎて部屋から出ないようにし
ておりませんがええ
心当たりが張っ
綺麗には心当たり関係ありますあの詐欺
サウンドにはまりすぎててああ今年の
サウナオブザイヤーに受賞されましたと
いう人に行かないん
昨日ガサが入ったんですけどもいつも行く
サーブがめっちゃ温度が高いんですね超
高くて肌が地は撮影になるから水辺の
ちょいが入るんですけどもそのさらに14
時以降すごい暑くなくなっちゃって完全に
アツアツではないんですの水風呂に入って
それがラストセットだったので水ブロディ
キンキンに冷えたなぁそれを上がって
しまいましたあ俺こんな饒舌でしゃべり
ますけど三重苦と3度ありますから
いやまぁお風呂入ってからあると思うん
ですけどもあの聞いてくれ御苦労の近くに
くっちゃべってた大学生が主語にいた
あいつらのせいでこれが入れなかった
さすがにベタベタ喋ってる人の近くに行き
たくなかったので僕はあの水風呂で
キンキンに冷えたまま上がって損は帰って
しまって脱げてしまったという状態で
ございますここで一つ言わせていきたい顔
はいさぶのでぺちゃくちゃしゃべって大学
生
根源の空がお前のサウナーじゃねーよもう
サブ謎な沿ってくるな人に迷惑かけるな某
局てもしも読めないのかこの馬鹿大学正門
嫁勉強してができてください p コ
ミュって30黒ってのはすごいかかって
みようかいました手が冷えピタ一つ菊薫る
んですけど崩落の可能性もあるので誰も a
に入れてないんですけどもほぼ確実にそれ
で近くあります寒かったです今日朝起きて
から寒気がしました
ん
[音楽]
上がった明日まで熱が続いてもちょっと
さすがに pcr 系素が入ってきます
以上ワクチン2回打ってるんでこれによっ
ても警鐘になるはずなんですけどどうみて
も10畳そして靴れてる大学生たちの戦で
僕はもう買ってか付けている
ちょっと頑張って下に降りますまで伝わら
ないと思いませんが頭に限界です何が
すごいかって
今は寒いからみてくれ
可愛いだろうサビどうぞここで何をしよう
かというと熱が出た時に人の体には冷やさ
なければいけない場所が何個かあるひとつ
はは気候が熱がよく排出されるところだ
ここ癒すことによって大量の低下に
つながるかもしれないかと首輪小出沢言っ
てたら誰かが後は後で彼をもう一つ大事な
がっ音が高熱すぎると9なんかその生殖
器官がダメな人はらしい結構パツパツの
やつを履かせ方がいいと思われこんな
ところで会だけが語れるのがう追い出せ
味覚嗅覚も問題に出した高剛性は絶対値し
たくないのでちょっとアスター治るまでは
おとなしくしてようと思うチーズ解熱剤に
なります1戦以上失礼します
じゃあ寝る準備にかかると思うこういう時
看病してくれる女の子がいたら俺は a
ないうちかいないと寒いので気を見ます
こういうふうに役立つんどが人をダメに
するゲーミングウェアこれで全身を温め
られ
ごま例えられるのかこれが高められるのか
それはダメだ
ちょっと父は
獅子は推奨しますこんな所で
俺の将来粒下げていかないこれでしっかり
とてずっと周りはピアしたほうがいいです
マジでこれを進めたんであとは部屋を
暖かくしてさせられてるんだけど足が書い
たほうがいい結婚熱出ること多いでこう
いう時マジうまいんですよ最後に温度だけ
測りますね
これ今日最初血管
me
ばいばいん
もうダメな花々見ながらと言うななんで熱
が上がり続けたって理由がかんじゃない
俺が動画を撮ってはしゃぎ続けてるから寝
ますおやすみなさい
やばいねー
普通にやばいぞこれは
普通に山頑張んなきゃいけない時に返却に
年末で高熱が出ておりますか今これ酒
よかっ
タブー悪魔的にあったけー税
いやーこれが
コツだあっ食べるのは大事なんですけど
温めてはいけない場所冷やした方が熱が
下がる場所がありますそこをしっかりと
冷やしつつ発汗汗をかくのが大事です
白けどおやすみなさい
いいいい
[音楽]
あ11時です
九寸な巨人が来るいい変わら
ユーチューバーっての熱で武田すんぞいっ
てね写真入りの居城前にちょっとしてる
から nice さあ酒絶対こうしなきゃ
いけないんだ3ロボ9暑いときに彼に水分
とって汗をかく発汗が熱は酒で最大の
ポイントです中間報告3つが出てから一時
買った横になってるけど変化背中見て
みようさすがにも
嘘をつくなんて思わねーなー
[音楽]
32区の4部今のところ変換なしだ妻なお
やすみ世界辛いおうううっ
ん
4日おめがああ
[音楽]
おはようございます朝になりました太陽が
まだわからないんですけど一回測ります
これで下がってなかったら俺はもう終わり
だ
[音楽]
頼むよちょっとあさってからまだ仕事
いっぱいあるからないっ
3位
なんと5分
ねますいっ
[音楽]
ブーバーどうぞ雪像です pcr 検査も
受けてきて無事陰性だったのでコロナの
可能性はかなり少ないと思います
なんですけど熱がねちょっとまたさがなく
て
ちょっと普通にやばい色で結構もう
本当は c 働き過ぎた可能性もある
マーサの奴多いんですよちょっと皆さんも
穴今気温が変わりやすいタイミングでまず
で気を付けて下さい俺みたいにならない
ように気を付けて下さいそれぞれの対応
だけ見せて終わります
おりな様ねえ38-80
と
30黒
病院行ってきます